What can Joe Biden get done without the Senate?
As I've mentioned a dozen times this week,
control of the Senate is not yet determined. There
are two run off Senate races in Georgia, which
will happen on January 5th. We'll be covering
them very extensively. If Democrats get both,
it will be 50/50, making Kamala Harris as vice
president the tie breaking vote. Democrats could
effectively control the Senate, but the question
is, without the Senate, what can get done? Let's
go through it. First of all, there's a long list
of executive orders. A lot of the disasters Donald
Trump got us into with executive orders, he can
get us out of anything Trump did unilaterally.
Joe Biden can undo unilaterally. And we've already
talked about getting back into Paris climate,
getting back into the show, getting rid
of the military trans ban, reinstating
the Dreamer program, doing a lot with
covid. And he's already launched a task
force. There's tons of agency stuff. You
know, Trump has reorient reoriented the EPA
to be weak. Joe Biden could reorient the EPA
to be stronger to protect the environment.
NASA was directed to stop studying climate. Joe
Biden can get NASA to be studying climate again.
So there is quite a bit that Joe Biden can do
foreign policy. Biden can do a lot of a lot of
foreign policy things that aren't budgetary and
thus need to go through the House and Senate.
But there's a lot of foreign policy. Fixing
relationships, fixing a bunch of the trade
stuff with China, if China is willing, maybe
getting us back into the Iran nuclear deal,
a lot of that can be done without controlling
the Senate. The stuff that will be difficult is,
you know, infrastructure, including green
infrastructure. You need the House and Senate
tax reform, real health care reform. You're
going to need the House and Senate for that
unless you make deals with the devil, essentially,
unless you make compromises that I can't imagine
Joe Biden would want to do. And that would be
sort of my one area of of caution, which is
it's great for Joe Biden to talk about. I will be
the president. Whether you voted for me or not,
I will be the president of the United
States, not just of blue states
rather than red states. It's great that Joe Biden
is saying that. It's great that Joe Biden is, you
know, a guy who has been able to work across the
aisle. These people are disgusting, though, these
Republicans. And the idea that you're going to get
your agenda done with their help is ridiculous.
You could maybe get Pyrrhic victories. The idea of
a Pyrrhic victory is you win, but you do so much
self-inflicted damage and winning that you end
up wondering, is that really a win anymore? And
the way that would work out as a Pyrrhic victory
would be you get something done on paper, but the
compromises you make damage the country in such
a way that it ends up being a wash, for example.
I think that's the risk of Joe Biden. I think
there would be a naivete if Joe Biden really
thinks he's going to work with these clowns.
My hope is and I don't pretend to know,
we'll see. And if it doesn't go this
way, we'll criticize Biden. My hope
is that Biden is using language of uniting the
American people, but he is not naively thinking
he's going to get a lot of this big stuff done by
working with Republicans because they're just not
going to work with him in any way. That would
approximate what we would call a leftward move.
It remains to be seen. I'm not putting the
cart before the horse. I will criticize
it if it happens. But I am going to hope and
lobby that Joe Biden accurately understands
that these are not people that you can negotiate
with or that you can bargain with because you
will just damage yourself. That's my sense
right now. I'd love to hear your thoughts.
We have a great bonus show today.
You can get instant access
by using the coupon code. Fresh start
when you sign up at join Pakman dot com.